Mình sẽ tụi lýng à mắt khá lê, mà chăm ngày 1, sau thông ngày 2, tôi mũ mắt bỏ kết điều khoản trong tâm chup kế hoạc hoạc bình,
gió tổng thống mấy đuần trong đề sốt, như việc hà mắt giải giá và phi quân sự hoa khá ra.
Châu dành người palestine phải tự quy định từng lại của mình.
Hà mắt cũng nèo cự tin sau xung đột, nhằm ngâm gió thấy hoa bởi tay, bà đồng trả tự xó tuy nhiên.
Thương đầy đoạn kết ở rập và mở giống chính dịch phản đối xer ạy trên nhiều mặt chật.
Pề phía nước lại, sáng cảm buộc hà mắt phát lời kế hoạc hoạc bình.
Theo thật hòa mỹ làm trung dài, hà mắt phải chẳng trả hà mi cám tý thể con tin từ ngày 18,
sau tính đổ chẳng khiến sẽ đoạn dạm giá vô lực lượng o tính của tế đảm nghiệp, lỡ chỉ hoán.
Kế hoạc cũng yêu cầu giữa mạo tăng bộ hà tăng buồn vừa vợi chương và chào quan trị cà ra của các nhóm buu trang.
Điều mà hà mắt cũng lên tính bá bỏ.
Chúng khi đó, tình như người ta y tích thủ liệu hàng, tất cả lực lượng tính hành nhiều đồ thông cách và các khu làng,
khiến người palestín thông phòng.
Y đẹp cho biết đã thực hiện hơn 3 mất của thông kích có mục tiêu.
Theo số liệu từ palestín có hơn, chính trong năm mới được thiệt vạn tại bởi tây và đông xer ủ sơ lêng
sâm sáng với khu xung đồ tài cà ra, kể từ thông mời năm 18, phông trong hà mi bà.